[Music]
and then I'll go silent and it'll go
then I go we're a thousand times worse
well if so the sound wasn't it I learned
that the sound didn't matter at all
because I used a o L for a really long
time and ahead to three blocks it had to
fill the three blocks it was like doggy
birth
yep and then like satellite waves and
then a man walking on to the internet or
whatever us and then it have little
words at the bottom there's something
that it would say retrieving and if it
hung on retrieving like it it should
flash by all those words like when a
game is loading yeah if it hung on
retrieving for like more than five
seconds you're at [ __ ] they're getting
on the Internet today at all there's no
[Music]
internet man I would say is probably
like movie news really or something like
that yeah yeah I like I don't remember
specifically but it would have been like
something related to the things I was
really interested in so it would have
either been a professional wrestling
website to find back story or find it
for fight movie news to find out more
about like the production of something
going on if you ever wanted to watch a
movie trailer you'd have to go get an
apple
they had movie trailers so that's where
everything would go so you'd like behind
guys did you hear about the new
spider-man trailer like Waiting g-spot
mm oh yeah there it's new one Tobey
Maguire yeah you go to Apple and you go
to trailers and that's how you would
watch it you would go to it and then you
would choose the size at which you would
want to download it so do you want it to
be like the size of a thumbnail or the
size of a like that note card or
something like that and then you would
you would download it and then because
if you try to do that with dial-up it
wouldn't work at all but if he tries he
that was cable eventually it would
download you'd come back like five
minutes later for making a sandwich and
then you watch the spider-man trailer
which is two and a half minutes you
think the Internet is amazing do
anything literally anything
I feel like with the rise of streaming
it's obvious that people love games as
media but not everyone is capable of
playing all the games like I'm very
fortunate that I work in the industry
and so if something comes out that I
want to play I just play it but I also
remember how I felt as a kid where you
know you could maybe get a game rented
for the weekend but if you get that one
you're picking between that five other
games that you're never gonna play ever
unless your friend owns then there's
like this whole trading system that you
have to come up with the play games
because you get like three a year do you
remember your LAN parties oh man I
didn't we did we would do stuff I was a
very much console kid growing up but
things like bringing up two friends that
had Nintendo 64's
and then two TVs and then playing
Goldeneye and we called an eighth player
but we weren't actually like you both
actually connect and you would just
playing I hear like where we all take
the same stage as though we were
together and we just bow each
fill-in-the-blanks but I think streaming
now is now the new extension of those
people who aren't able to play
everything I think it's the game
experience but I think it's also the
game play too because I mean for me I
will I stream a lot right so I watch a
lot of streams of overwatch cope or
Street Fighter do these are games that I
play I can play those games but I can't
play them like that
gotcha so I think there's a certain
aspect of well I can just rent this
streamer's ability I'm just gonna watch
them again a 10 kill streak in fortnight
and then win there's definitely are a
competitive aspect to where you enjoy
the competitive nature game experiencing
the game and everything like that but I
think there's also an aspect of feeling
like you're you're putting yourself in
the shoes exactly if you're saying like
watching the Super Bowl and imagining
what it would be like to be in the Super
Bowl
[Music]
kind of goes back to the road you know
the two Nintendo 64 things like you have
to have eight friends all capable and
interested in this thing which you know
if you live in us in a small town in a
small neighborhood that may not be the
case the Internet makes it so easy that
everything has a friends list and I mean
I'm sure if I was younger and I was
playing like an overwatch match and I
got along pretty well on the voice chat
with someone like I would absolutely
send them a friend request and like you
build a relationship like yeah when I
hate when Elise and I first met it was
all anonymous like the Internet is
anonymous now but I feel like it was a
hundred times more anonymous back then
because there was no social media there
was nothing that tied you to your
internet persona or personality now it's
someone on Twitter who will say
something but and but their avatar so
picture of that
[Music]
there I mean I definitely remember all
your base that was a big one
and then there was badger badger badger
badger mushroom there the memes
originally were just like these things
that you pass around and people would
transform go to and so but those I
revert those a lot those two definitely
you